check this out Marjorie Taylor green
tried to make a statement about how not
racist she is and in doing so she made a
horribly racist comment I'm gonna play
this for you it is some really really
wild stuff
and uh I'll just play it for you and
then we'll talk about it I know a ton of
white people that are as lazy and sorry
and and probably worse than black people
I know
hahaha
Marjorie Taylor green
to prove to us how not racist she is
says you know what I'm not racist lots
of white people are even as or lazier
than black people I know that might be
hard to believe if if you can believe
this
there are also lazy white people who
challenge black people for laziness did
that just come out wrong Marjorie or am
I misunderstanding what it is that you
were saying there's actually a uh a
longer clip
um that I'm trying to find let me see if
I can find it here which gives a little
more more context
lazier I think would be the key word
here
uh
uh no I'm not able to find Okay so
it it did this is really a a disgusting
person really a disgusting person and
during this same this was during like a
live that she did of some kind answering
questions I don't know
she said on the issue of Confederate
statues black people should actually be
proud of Confederate statues because
it's a reminder of how far the country
has come this is crazy I don't want our
statues taken down in our country I
don't think you remove or erase history
so I do I do agree those statues
shouldn't be taken down right they're
part of our history we should learn from
our history we don't erase it but that
doesn't make me a racist because I just
like as I say leave the statue up there
if I were black people today and I
walked by one of those statues I would
be so proud because I'd say look how far
I have come in this country look how far
my people have what they have overcome
and these are good things yeah it's just
like you know in Germany if they had
Hitler statues obviously we would all
say these are great reminders of how far
we've come we used to have Hitler here
and now we've come so far and so the
more Hitler statues you have the better
reminder it is of how far we've come
what an imbecilic thing to say now I
have gone back and forth over the last
you know couple years that Marjorie
Taylor Green's been around
as to whether she's really this dumb or
whether this is sort of a character
she's playing
this live thing really gives me the
impression that she's genuinely this
dumb I don't I don't think this is a
character that she's playing
um let me know what you think but I have
a very hard time believing that this is
staged in any sense of the word